soy geógrafo me encanta decirle sobre
todo aquí estudié geografía y me dedico
profesionalmente a la geografía
pero siento desilusionados no me sé los
nombres de los ríos de las montañas y de
los países
no soy un trivial con patas lo siento
pero no la geografía es mucho más la
geografía estudia analiza explora
transforma el mundo es una ciencia que
relaciona a los seres humanos con el
planeta en el que habitamos
hace 10.000 años vivíamos la revolución
neolítica el hombre se hizo sedentario
el ser humano y vivíamos en cuevas y a
través de la ventana de la cueva
podíamos ver cómo se desarrolla nuestro
entorno más local más cercano hoy en día
a través de la ventana de nuestros
dispositivos móviles podemos ver cómo se
desarrolla el mundo global
y gracias eso ha sido gracias en gran
parte a la tecnología ya mí la
tecnología es algo que me fascina
pero todo va muy deprisa según el foro
económico mundial en el año 2025 dentro
de cinco años
habrá más máquinas inteligentes
trabajando que personas
eso es preocupa nos preocupa para el
futuro de vuestra profesión de vuestros
estudios a mí sí me preocupa mucho ver
qué haremos a las puertas de la quinta
revolución industrial
y en este sentido que hacen un recorrido
por
la geografía y la tecnología quiero
pensar cómo puede ser el futuro de
geografía y para ello tengo que imaginar
cómo será la geografía del futuro los
invito acompañarme en este recorrido y
al mismo tiempo a que cambie es la
palabra geografía por vuestra profesión
o por vuestros estudios porque al final
esta 5ª revolución industrial nos afecta
a todos por igual
vivimos en el planeta tierra el planeta
físico pero también vivimos en otro
planeta en el ciberespacio en el que
conocemos a gente que nunca veremos
personalmente
usamos dinero digital nos movemos por
autopistas de la información compartimos
todo en internet al final estamos
uniendo la parte física de las personas
con la parte digital con la parte
digital y de los robots
si unimos la palabra geografía y la
palabra tecnología obtenemos geo
tecnología si suena un poco raro la
palabra pero es más sencillo que parece
hablamos de los satélites que están
encima de nosotros y hablamos del gps
que está en nuestro móvil y al mismo
tiempo estamos hablando de los mapas y
de la información geográfica
la biotecnología es una industria que
genera al año 72 billones de dólares de
beneficio
el 69% de las búsquedas en google tienen
alguna componente de geolocalización
asociada
y luego hay otro elemento que son los
datos todo el mundo y vamos a hablar de
los datos la industria los datos genera
500 billones de dólares anualmente de
beneficio todos compartimos nuestra
ubicación con los móviles
sabéis cuántas veces se puede llegar a
compartir esa ubicación al día
una 10 100.000 14 mil veces la ubicación
la compartimos 14 mil veces al día
y eso parece mucho y realmente lo es
porque estamos pasando de un proceso de
transformación digital de digitalización
a un proceso de ratificación el grupo de
rock metallica elige los países donde va
a tocar y las canciones que va a tocar
en función de lo que escuchan sus fans
en spotify y spotify no vende canciones
vende los datos de las emociones que nos
producen las canciones cuando los
seguimos en un momento determinado y
cuando le seguimos en un sitio
determinado
y lo más fascinante es que todo esto
también es geografía
pero además de la tecnología podemos
hablar de otro tipo de tecnologías
hablamos de internet a las cosas de
block change the big data de smart city
hay muchas tecnologías que van a afectar
tanto a la geografía como al resto de
profesiones quiero hacer un recorrido
por 5
ámbitos de actuación que son los cinco
ámbitos de actuación del geógrafo a
través de diez tecnologías y además así
veréis que los geógrafos no solo
estudiamos ríos montañas y países vamos
allá el primer ámbito son las
tecnologías de la información geográfica
la información geográfica tiene que ver
con datos los datos cuando le añadimos
la geolocalización valen mucho más por
cierto cuánto vale un dato hay empresas
que compran y venden datos
geolocalizados sabéis cuánto vale el
dato de un usuario al mes de una persona
el tuyo el tuyo el tuyo un euro por un
euro puedo comprar esos datos con
trescientos euros
tengo todos los datos de lo que habéis
hecho y dónde os habéis movido el último
mes
por otra parte hablamos de big data de
grandes volúmenes de datos
hablamos de smart data de datos
inteligentes hablamos de open data de
datos abiertos públicos compartidos
mucha información alrededor de la
localiza geolocalización con esos datos
que al final tiene que ver con la
movilidad la movilidad tiene que ver con
cómo desplazarnos de un sitio a otro y
precisamente un geógrafo en el futuro se
tiene que preguntar si esa movilidad no
sobre va a ser automática si a través de
los coches autónomos y las carreteras
inteligentes al final conseguiremos
evitar problemas de masificación por
ejemplo en el turismo porque las propias
carreteras o los coches ya nos llevarán
donde hay menos masificación y también
donde se pueda producir menos
contaminación
el segundo ámbito de actuación es la
planificación urbanística
la planificación urbanística en este
caso tiene que ver con el internet de
las cosas todo va a estar conectado
personas cosas objetos nos convertidos
en nodos de información en puntos que
emiten información y que reciben
informaciones y toda esa información se
queda en la nube claro que esto tiene
puede causar algunos problemas por
ejemplo el año 2016 hubo un hackeo de
electrodomésticos que tenemos todos en
nuestra casa conectados a la red y a
través de ellos se atacaron páginas web
de netflix amazon del guardián o de la
cnl
y eso es un problema y además el
internet de las cosas solo puede
funcionar con una tecnología muy
avanzada en este caso esa tecnología es
el 5g tecnología 5g nos va a permitir
tener mucha cantidad de información que
llegue rápidamente a nuestros móviles
compartirla a tiempo real compartirla de
forma ininterrumpida y además aunque
haya mucha gente
estamos viendo que hay una auténtica
guerra por el 5g un geógrafo en términos
de geopolítica de gobernanza se deberá
preguntar en el futuro
y deberá afirmar digo yo quien controle
el 5g controlará o dominará el mundo
el tercer ámbito de actuación es el
desarrollo territorial o la ordenación
del territorio
estamos hablando de territorios
inteligentes hablamos de territorios
smart la inteligencia no es más que el
paso de la información al conocimiento
aportando un valor que nos ayude a tomar
decisiones con ese conocimiento que
hemos creado se dice que la inteligencia
artificial en pocos años va a superar la
inteligencia humana emiratos árabes
unidos- tiene ya un ministro de
inteligencia artificial
vital es el nombre del consejero
delegado de una empresa de capital
riesgo de hong kong
pero ese consejo de legado es muy
especial no es una persona es una
inteligencia artificial que tiene voz y
voto en el consejo de administración de
la empresa
y en finlandia están dando cursos
gratuitos a toda la población sobre
inteligencia artificial para educarla y
alfabetizar la en este ámbito
un geógrafo del futuro se preguntará si
esto avanza así realmente llegará un día
en que nos gobernará una inteligencia
artificial desde un punto de vista
práctico quizás sea más justa más
eficiente más objetiva pero claro de
momento no tiene emociones bueno pues
las programamos yo me pregunto quién
programará esas emociones
podrán llegar tener emoción en las
máquinas pero quien las programe tendrá
que evitar sesgos humanos como sexo la
raza la religión aspectos económicos
para que sea lo más justo posible
y además de la parte de la inteligencia
artificial tenemos otra serie de
elementos por ejemplo una tecnología que
nos da mucha seguridad frente al otro
que nos puede causar inseguridad que es
el blogs en un protocolo de
transferencia de información segura y
descentralizada más fácil un certificado
digital algo que nos va a permitir que
decir que algo ha sucedido en un sitio y
en un momento concreto y justificarlo
eso desde punto de vista un geógrafo lo
que nos permitirá es decir bueno pues
podemos definir realmente dónde hay una
frontera el linde de una parcela por qué
porque los mapas mienten los mapas
dependen de quien los haga en zonas de
conflicto geopolítico la frontera está
en un sitio o en otro dependiendo de
quien haga ese mapa o desde donde se vea
con blogs y con esa seguridad nos
permitirá confirmar que realmente dónde
se encuentra esa frontera
el cuarto ámbito de actuación es el
medio ambiente trabajamos los geógrafos
mucho con el medio ambiente relacionado
con el espacio en mi ambiente es algo
físico que estamos acostumbrados a ver
día a día pero se puede aumentar con la
realidad aumentada podemos incorporar
elementos digitales por ejemplo podemos
ver cómo puede suceder una inundación y
afectarnos podemos ver cómo puede
cambiar un cambio climático en un sitio
concreto oa nivel global y podemos
intentar prever lo que va a suceder
adelantarnos y reducir por tanto la
incertidumbre y los impactos también
podemos utilizar la red virtual para
reconstruir un paisaje antiguo para
crear nuevos paisajes para poder
trabajar con esos ecosistemas sin tener
que desplazarnos allí evitando todos los
problemas de movilidad de huella de
carbono de desplazamiento eso se podrá
hacer también con la realidad virtual
por tanto un geógrafo en el futuro se
preguntara si seremos capaces de recrear
la naturaleza de la mejor forma posible
sin realizar un impacto sobre la misma y
de esta forma poder
reducir los impactos que nos produce
y otra tecnología es por ejemplo la
impresión 3d y lo digo soy más lento
porque dices buena impresión 3d que
tiene que ver bueno se imprimen pequeños
objetos imprimió lujosa más grandes sean
llega a imprimir un coche sea llegó a
imprimir una casa en impresión 3d y
claro un geógrafo se pregunta en el
futuro porque no imprimimos una montaña
podremos imprimir una montaña es más si
se imprimen o si están intentar imprimir
tejidos vivos para el cuerpo humano con
impresoras 3d porque una montaña viva
para recuperar una ladera que esté
dañada al final es una especie de
tiritas digitales que podemos intentar
poner a naturaleza y si ya sé que lo
mejor es no hacer ese daño a naturaleza
pero una vez lo hemos hecho por qué no
intentar solucionarlo gracias a la
tecnología
el quinto gran ámbito de trabajo es la
sociedad del conocimiento desde la
geografía estudiamos los censos de
población y sabemos dónde está la gente
cómo son las personas qué
características sociodemográficas tienen
pero y los robots hay muchísimos robots
humanoides pero no conozco que hay
ascensos de robots habrá que hacer
censos de robots y preguntarse dónde
están esos robots cómo se mueven son
públicos son privados son humanoides qué
capacidad tienen e integrar los procesos
de población para poder identificar lo
que están haciendo e incluso hay unos
pequeños robots que manchan bots que
también lo están cambiando todo antes la
comunicación era de humano a humano
después pasamos de humano a máquina pero
es que las máquinas empiezan a hablar
entre ellas y de pronto en el futuro
puede pasar a nivel comercial un impacto
como que no vayamos a comprar porque sea
la propia casa domótica la que en
función de nuestros gustos y consumos
mensuales haga los pedidos atiendan a
online y le lleguen a casa y eso poder
revolucionar muchas cosas son cosas que
debemos plantearnos
seriamente desde la geografía
al final
la geografía del futuro es la que nos va
a permitir imaginar cómo será ese futuro
de la geografía
horacio cap el catedrático de geografía
recibió el año 2008 el equivalente al
nobel de geografía y dice en sus
memorias
hay muchos futuros posibles algunos
mejores que otros nosotros podemos
ayudar a construirlos a la pregunta
inicial de si la geografía realmente va
a cambiar no va a cambiar va a seguir
siendo la misma van a seguir viendo ríos
montañas así viendo países lo que va a
cambiar es en nuestra relación con la
tecnología hemos de encontrar un
equilibrio el equilibrio entre lo físico
y lo digital entre las personas y los
robots entre los emociones las emociones
y los algoritmos y al final la
tecnología tiene que ser siempre al
servicio del ser humano y no al revés
siempre que de estar alrededor el ser
humano es más si nos preguntamos cómo
puede cambiar la tecnología por ejemplo
el mercado de trabajo eso que da tanto
miedo de que vamos a ser sustituidos en
absoluto justamente la profesión
que tienen elementos no sustituibles son
las que más van a costar aquellas que
hablan de creatividad de empatía de
elementos que las máquinas no pueden
cambiar
en definitiva la tecnología dice que
estamos hechos de bits
pero la geografía nos dice que estamos
hechos de lugares muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]